あっ、もうダメだ。二重になってるなう。
すげー寝不足だった最近。
一昨日、睡眠時間ゼロ。昨日、二時間。
で、やっと今日ちょっと寝れたんですけど。
やっぱもうほぼ二徹するとねぇ、一回寝るだけじゃちょっと体力が回復しないんで。
今日はちょっと一日寝てました。はじめしゃちょーです。
皆ちゃんと寝たほうがいいよ。ホントに。
はいっというわけで今日の動画は～毎月恒例質問コーナーの募集のしゃんしゃしゃーいーっす。
（拍手）
いやっ、ダメだ。ちゃんとやろう。
質問コーナー募集の動画でーす
今月はちょっと思考を変えていこうと思ってます。
えっといつもだとその「youtubeのコメント欄にコメントしてね！」ってこうやるんですけど。
今日は違うよ！
今回はTwitterの方で募集しようと思います。
僕のTwitterのアカウントはこちらでございまーす。イェイ！
おぉー待て待て。
リプライを送るんじゃない。リプライを送るんじゃないぞ。
僕のTwitterにコメントするんじゃなくて、ハッシュタグをつけて
ツイートしてください。
僕のTwitterに質問くると皆さんのTwitterが..
ブルブル
とりあえずハッシュタグをつけて僕への質問とかリクエスト、一言コメント。
なんでもいいんで
ハッシュタグをつけてつぶやくと僕が絶対確認します。安心してください。
なんだろうな。ハッシュタグ。ハッシュタグ。
なんかもっと、ひ、ひねりがほしいなぁ。ひねりがほしいなぁ。
よしっこれにしましょう。というわけで今回こちらです。（笑）
はじめしゃちょー謝肉祭っと打った後に
僕への質問とかねコメントをなんでもいいので書いてください。
あ、僕のTwitterに送るんじゃないですよ。
もうホントハッシュタグつけてつぶやいてくれるだけで確認するので。
今回はそういう感じでいっていきましょう。
もう３月だよ～びっくりだよ～寝たいよ～
えっとTwitterのハッシュタグ質問の期限なんですけども
３月の１５日までにTwitterでよかったらハッシュタグをつけてコメントを書きまくってください。
もう何回でも書いていいよ。
暴言もなんでも吐いて～
ちょっと嫌だなあ
暴言はほどほどにしてくれればありがたいです。
よかったらもうなんでも書いてください。
質問じゃなくもいいし、リクエストでもいい。
もぉ～文句でもなんでもいいですよ。
ホントにもぉ～なんでもホントに書いちゃってください。
ホントにもうなんでもいいんで。
というわけで。
というわけで3月の質問コーナー質問募集してるのでもう皆さんのセンスにまかせます。
もうなんでも書いちゃってください。
もうこれバシッとやりますか、もう。
３月の最終日だ。
３月の３１日までに出します。
３月の最終日に多分はじめしゃちょー謝肉祭の動画がでるので。
いや、ホントちょっとあのぉ～君たちセンスいい人が多いからね。
俺は知ってるよ。
コメント欄で何度笑ったことか。
今回もちょっと君たちの素晴らしいセンスに期待してコメントお待ちしております。
まぁ真面目な質問でもいいですし、もうめちゃくちゃ面白い質問でもいいです。
もう僕の気分で選ばせて頂くんで。
よかったら皆さんの質問お待ちしております。
こちらで…こうね、こうこうこう…ここですから
ハッシュタグTwitterね。youtubeのコメントじゃないよ。ここですから。
はじめしゃちょー謝肉祭で。
ちょっとねぇ～ちょいちょいやることが多くて。
とりあえず筋肉痛を治して、しっかり寝て。
白猫プロッ...　フッ..
エエンッ
ゲームもほどほどにしてね。
よかったら皆さんのコメントお待ちしております。
じゃあな。
おやすみ。
もう今日は体バキバキ。すぐ寝るよ。